time to load up on black roots because
Willow is back on Disney plus well the
original Styles return who's behind the
new series we've got the answers
at the 2020 Disney investor Day event on
December 10 2020 the company revealed
that the willow sequel series will
Premiere sometime in 2022. the exact
date was revealed in a teaser unveiled
at Star Wars celebration in May 2022.
text on screen noted it will premiere on
November 30th 2022 on Disney plus the
first season of The Willow series will
consist of Eight Episodes according to
IMDb they'll air on Wednesday nights
beginning November 30th taking the place
of Andor in the Disney plus release
schedule it's not clear yet if Disney
plans for more Willow Beyond this season
or if the story will end after just one
in a May 2019 appearance on MTV's happy
sad confused podcast Ron Howard
confirmed that original Willow star
Warwick Davis would reprise his role as
a kind-hearted farmer and aspiring
sorcerer Willow of good work is so cool
and so good and he's just he's such a
good actor a Salesman mad Martin he was
played by Val Kilmer in the original
won't be returning however at the d23 in
September 2022 Disney revealed that
Christian Slater will be playing mad
Martin's friend although the character's
name hasn't yet been specified Joanne
Wally will be reprising her role as
sorsha the warrior daughter of Queen
bavmorda Kevin Pollock and Rick Overton
will also be reprising their roles as
Rule and franzine according to
Entertainment Weekly they'll be joined
by Ruby Cruz who's playing Sasha's
daughter kit Erin kellyman who's playing
kids companion and a knight in training
named Jade Amar cheddar Patel who's
playing the thief Borman Ellie Bama as a
kitchen made Dove Ralph innocent as
Commander Balaton Charlie
Alexis Rodney as Lachlan Kenny Knights
as Keane and Warwick Davis's daughter
Annabelle as Mims other cast members and
unspecified roles include Roosevelt or
renti sellers Tony ravalori Dempsey
brick and to Lisa Garcia
the willow TV series is created by
Jonathan kazdan who wrote the pilot and
is also the show's co-showrunner along
with Wendy Miracle kazdan is also
credited as a writer of the first
season's last two episodes custom also
co-wrote the screenplay for solo a Star
Wars story and wrote and directed the
films the first time and in the Land of
Women miracle was a showrunner for the
CW's arrow and was co-executive producer
on the Disney Plus show Big Shot she's
written and produced several other TV
series the first two episodes of the
series were directed by Stephen
wolfenden wolfenden was the second unit
director on all three Fantastic Beasts
movies as well as four of the Harry
Potter films he also has 15 TV directing
credits going back to 2005. the
directors of the following episodes have
yet to be announced Ron Howard who
directed the original 1988 film is an
executive producer
Howard has suggested that with Davis
returning as the title character fans
will get to see a more mature side to
the hero the sequel series will take
place approximately 30 years after the
movie and Howard indicated on the happy
sad confused podcast that the show will
be a continuation of the film Story the
end of the film saw Willow obtain a
magic book that would help him on his
journey to becoming a sorcerer after so
bravely projecting the baby from the
queen and her evil forces what we know
about the story so far is that it begins
when kids the daughter of sorcer and the
princess gathers a group of friends to
search for Willow who is indeed now a
sorcerer they need his help because
Kit's twin brother a prince has been
kidnapped once Willow agrees he promises
a grand Journey we must go beyond the
edge of our world in addition to the May
2022 teaser Disney released a
full-length trailer at d23 in September
the trailer starts off with our hero
kids revealing what likely promises to
be a major theme of the series you think
you know what is real and what isn't
what is light what is dark now forget
all you know and come with me kitten her
companions travel a long way to find
Willow and beg him to join their mission
because they need his magic we then get
some glimpses of returning characters
including sorcer Rule and franzine next
Willow makes clear the stakes of their
situation a powerful as yet a known
enemy is out there marshaling the forces
of evil and only Willow and his
companions can stop it Willow uses a
flamethrower at one point the trailer
ends with another of the show's themes
when the villain challenges Willow to
explain how he's going to defeat them
Willow responds will do it the same way
as last time
with my friends
the original Willow had a PG rating for
its fantasy violence Common Sense Media
calls it appropriate for children ages
10 and up the movie can at times be
quite dark after all it's about an evil
queen who sends an entire Army to kill a
baby along the way Milo mad Martin
sorcia and the gang battle all kinds of
fantasy creatures often dismembering
them
what's going on smells like a battle
well the sequel series have similarly
violent moments at this point is unclear
but it will be chock full of scary
monsters so parents with really young
children might want to sit this one out
kids who can handle the original movie
should probably be fine watching the
series though
if you bought the Disney Plus
subscription so you can check out the
willow sequel series here's some good
news the streaming platform also
includes the 1988 movie if you don't yet
have a Disney Plus subscription the
original Willow is available for rental
or purchase on several other streaming
platforms if you prefer physical media
Willow is also available on Blu-ray and
DVD the 30th anniversary edition of the
movie was released in early 2019 and
includes all new title artwork
[Music]
thank you